so hello my name is Philip Alton I'm an
engineer on the chrome and web platform
team at Google and I'm really excited to
talk to you all today about this because
container queries is actually one of my
favorite topics and it's a feature I've
been waiting for for a long long time
and so I've lot to say about it so let's
let's dive right in
so container queries are kind of
actually a contentious topic and to
fully understand why you have to know
their history like many things in this
area their history starts with
responsive design so in 2010 Ethan
Marcotte published responsive web design
on a list apart and changed the way we
think about web design forever web
developers can now build sites with one
set of styles and confidently serve
those styles to any device but over the
next year so you started to see the same
questions popping up over and over again
as the web matured and it's modular
component based architecture started to
gain popularity a lot of people were
noticing the limitations of using media
queries to build responsive designs in
2013 prominent voices in the community
like nicholas gallagher we're starting
to suggest that responsive designs
should really be component based rather
than viewport based and folks like
jonathan neal even started proposing
actual new syntax that could support
element based media queries in CSS but
probably the most influential thing came
in April of 2013 a post by ian storm
taylor which was on the front page of
hacker news for a while and he called
media queries a hack he said they're
anti Maalik modular because they couple
component definitions to the design and
layout of a particular site he said that
what we really need are element queries
and this article is largely responsible
for popularizing that term so a few days
after that after getting slammed with
requests for this feature my colleague
and CSS working group member Tabb Atkins
wrote a reply that summarizes the
problems with element queries and it's
kind of become the de facto response
from the CSS working group whenever
developers asked for this feature
so I'll explain tapped argument in a
second but for now the main thing I want
you to understand is that despite the
many valid points that Tabb brought up
developers myself included still wanted
element queries to be a thing blog posts
continue to be written outlining exactly
why element queries are needed for
example this one from the filament group
includes a great example that I think
perfectly illustrates the problem so
with media queries you can build a
calendar widget like this one and it
works great on both desktop and mobile
but it only works if the calendar widget
is rendered in the content area that's
the same width as the screen as you can
see here if you try to put the calendar
in a sidebar it will break because the
media queries still report a wide
viewport so what we need is the ability
for the calendar to detect that it's in
a narrow context and render itself
accordingly and to prove that this isn't
just a contrived example here's a view
of Google's newly redesigned calendar at
Google calm
on desktop and here's the same calendar
rendered in Gmail in a sidebar no this
is not not only is this calendar being
reused in a different view it's being
reused in entirely different web
application to separate code bases using
the same component so this is a
real-world example of how responsive
design is clearly about more than just
page layouts it's definitely about
component layouts but since browsers
weren't implementing element queries
natively developers started to build
polyfills and since there was no
official syntax each polyfill kind of
made up its own syntax unofficial syntax
and the problem with inventing your own
syntax is it creates a potential future
compatibility risk something we see a
lot in the JavaScript community recent
examples like smoosh gate come to mind
in 2014 the responsive images community
group started to try to standardize a
trellis
excuse-me started a standardization
effort for element queries and after
their you know heroic work getting the
picture element standardized and
browsers developers had high hopes
unfortunately though the work was met
with a lot of ease
distance from browser vendors as well as
from a CSS working group in 2015
Matt Marquis wrote an article and lists
apart about the challenges they were
facing and he explained that element
queries at least in the current form
were essentially dead given the
resistance and challenges related to
ailment queries the group pivoted to
something they thought might be a little
bit easier to get through the standard
bodies and so they called it container
queries and thus this new term was born
so instead of having CSS conditionally
target an element itself it targets the
elements immediate parent unfortunately
while it's true that container queries
is less problematic than element queries
they're still problematic and there were
strong resistance from browsers to
implement them but once again despite no
implementation in browsers developers
kept on asking Chris coiour hypothesize
on Twitter that if element queries were
real they'd be used more often than
meaty queries and Scott GL took one step
further and he said that he would almost
never use media queries
if element queries existed so the
question is if container queries are
useful in design and developers clearly
want them
why don't they exist it almost feels
like there's this epic battle between
web developers and browser makers where
neither side fully understands the other
Jeremy Keith describes the sentiment
quite well in a post he published about
a year ago in his blog according to him
browser makers always claim they want
real-world feedback from actual
developers but when developers tell them
that they want container queries browser
makers kind of don't know what to say
and to be honest in my experience this
is mostly true so you have browser
makers so I mean you know it begs the
question have browser makers just put on
their evil goatees are we stuck in some
weird dystopian timeline where
developers don't get any say in the
future of the web so before we get too
cynical let's look back at why browser
makers are concerned about container
queries due to the way CSS works in
browsers today container queries present
to primarily two primary problems
the first and I think the one a lot of
people are familiar with is the kind of
infinite loop recursion problem and the
second much less familiar one is that
they actually break the Cascade so
consider consider these two CSS rules
the first one defines an element that
defaults to 500 pixels wide
the second conditionally overrides the
first rule to say if the element ever
gets larger than 500 pixels wide make it
499 pixels instead however if we make it
499 pixels then the selector will no
longer match but this means we're back
to just the first selector matching and
remember the first electric tells the
browser to make the element 500 pixels
wide and that means the second selector
now matches again and you can see we
have a problem we're in an infinite loop
and there's not an obvious way to
resolve this and note that this problem
doesn't just apply to element queries it
also applies to container queries
oftentimes in CSS an element size is
determined by the size of its children
this is known as shrink to fit and it
can happen with things like inline block
and floats like in this example so here
we have a container that has floated
left and a child element with a declared
width of 500 pixels and since the
container is floated it'll be the same
width as this child so it's also 500
pixels wide but the next rule says in
the event that the containers width is
500 pixels or greater the child's width
should be set to 499 pixels however
since the container is floated changing
the child's width to 480 pixels will
also change the containers worth to 499
pixels and now you can see that we have
the same problem we did before so it's
so that's how container queries can lead
to infinite loops but let's look about
how look at how they break fundamental
assumptions all browsers currently make
about the Cascade in order to understand
why this is the case you have to first
have a basic understanding of how
browsers take HTML and CSS and render
content to the screen so all browsers
currently process HTML and CSS and at
least three distinct phases style layout
and paint you might have heard of these
before and before then I explained them
I want it to make sure one thing is
clear these
phases are distinct and they're
sequential meaning that each one must
completely finish before the next one
starts and that's very important so to
understand why this has to be the case
let's take a look at the style face and
this part of the talk is going to get a
little bit technical so feel free to
zone out if you want to so in the South
phase the browser goes through every
single element in the Dom it matches it
with selectors in the CSS and then it
determines what values should apply to
every single CSS property the browser
supports and this is known as the
Cascade note that browsers most browsers
support hundreds of CSS properties and
most websites have hundreds if not
thousands of style rules and Dom
elements so it's critically important
that this process can run as efficiently
and quickly as possible so I think most
people in this room probably understand
how things like specificity and source
order work so all all goats this quickly
when doing cell calculations you always
have to start with the root element in
the tree and traverse down most of the
time the element is your HTML but in
this kind of trivial example the root
element is a section so the reason you
have to start at the root element is
because some CSS properties are
inherited which means that you have to
compute the full set of properties for
the parent before you can move on to the
child in this case only one rule matches
the section element the universal
selector and so those are the only
values we apply in this in the Cascade
for this element and actually that's not
quite true
technically you also need to list the
default values for every CSS property
that's not mentioned by any specific
rule and so that looks like this which
you know it's just a little bit verbose
so for the purposes of these examples
I'm gonna kind of imply this that I'm
not going to list every single property
that the browser supports in every
single case also technically you don't
use the kind of shorthand you use the
longhand for all these properties but
again this is a getting into the details
it's easier just to show the individual
properties that match to the rules
defined in the CSS so next we come to
the UL and we'll do the same for it as
you can see there's four properties and
two rules and the parent element doesn't
have any non default inheritable
properties so those don't apply so this
is kind of the full set of properties
and it gets more interesting though when
we get to the Li as you can see two
rules match but due to source order the
second padding declaration overrides the
first one and so this is the computed
set of properties we're not quite done
yet because the Li is a child of the UL
and that has a color defined and color
is inheritable so you have to add that
to the list anyway sorry if this is
getting too into the weeds but it's
actually really easy to see how this
works
when you look in your browsers developer
tools all you have to do is select any
Dom element and then you can look at the
style pane and see all the properties
that are calculated and I'm explain why
this is really important so with regard
to this pipeline now that we're done
with style only now can we start layout
so once again we begin from the root
element and we do what's called kind of
at least in chrome we call this
calculating the the box tree but you
have to you know you have to take the
full set of cascaded properties for an
element and then you calculate all the
kind of rectangular coordinates of
everything in the Dom so in this case we
know that this element is the the root
element so it starts out in the top left
at 0 0 and since the default width of a
block element is auto we know that it's
going to fill up all the entire space
and in this case let's just imagine as
600 pixels wide we don't yet know the
height because we have to go through all
of the the tree but we'll get to that
next the UL is very similar it kind of
takes up the same space as the section
but when you get to the Li now we can
actually start kind of developing this
box tree but the the important thing to
remember here and you know none of these
details are important they're all kind
of I'm just kind of faking this example
but the the critically important thing
to remember is that we can't do layout
unless we know what all of the styles
are so we have to do all the Styles
first and then we have to do layout we
can't do them at the same time okay so
the mostly boring part is over but the
main point to understand from all of
that and you'll see why it's important
in a second is you have to do style
before layout so imagine now that we
tried to implement container queries
imagine you're a browser and you're
going to implement container queries in
your browser rendering engine
so look at this HTML and CSS again now
let's add another rule that has a
container query so as you can see this
rule conditionally targets li elements
if the parent UL is wide enough so now
let's try to compute what the castigated
property values would be for the li if
you look closely you'll notice that
there are two different values for the
Flex property so the question is which
one should be applied well the only way
to answer this question is to know how
wide the UL is is it wider than 500
pixels or is it not wider than 500
pixels but since we haven't done layout
yet we don't have that information if
you allow selectors to query based on
layout information then you suddenly go
from a sequential rendering pipeline to
something like this in this model we do
style again after layout but since doing
style again might completely change the
results of the Cascade you also have to
do layout again but doing layout again
may completely change what selectors
match which means you have to do style
again and you have to repeat this
process over and over again until
everything kind of settles in there no
more changes and only then can you move
on so this is much much much much slower
than what we have currently today and
given what I just showed you I actually
think it's a good thing that browsers
pushed back and didn't implement
container queries when developers asked
if they had and they had done it exactly
how developers wanted the web would be
significantly slower today and nobody
wants that but there is good news the
reason I said this isn't the darkest
timeline is because there are a few
events in the history of container
queries that I actually skipped over and
didn't mention the truth is browser
makers have actually been working hard
to come up with performance solutions to
this problem for example in 2015 chrome
started implementing a feature called
CSS containment this gives developers a
way to tell the browser what parts of
the page layout are independent of other
parts and browsers can make lots of
rendering options rendering
optimizations based on this it also
paves the way for potentially avoiding
the circularity issue I brought it
before for example with CSS containment
you can specify that element size cannot
be affected by any of its descendants no
matter how big or small they might be
and despite the appearance and belief by
some that browser makers and web
developers are at war this is definitely
not the case there are actually many
examples of browser engineers reaching
out to developers and engaging with them
to see if the features that they're
specifying will actually end up helping
solve real problems that the developers
are facing in fact I know there are
plenty of browser engineers here today
who would love to talk to all of you
myself included so continuing on in 2016
chrome started working on a feature
called resize observer which is one of
my absolute favorite new web api's
resize observer lets web developers
performant ly monitor size changes to
any element on the page with a simple
callback function previously you could
only observe changes to the entire
window but obviously we know that it's
possible for elements to change their
size even if the window doesn't change
and then finally in January of this year
chrome shipped resize observer which
means the feature is now available to
over two billion users worldwide so
where does that leave us today well some
of these new features may seem cool we
still don't have container queries right
well if you screen your eyes hard enough
and you're willing to take the
definition of container queries very
very annoyingly literally and then we
actually have had container queries
since the beginning of CSS for example
here we define some initial styles for
an input and header element then we
conditionally override these styles
based on the state classes that can be
applied to these elements containers I
mean a selector is essentially a query
right so these are kind of like
container queries and we can actually
use the same concept to build something
today that I think is as good if not
even better than the container queries
that developers have been asking for and
I call this responsive components so let
me show you what I mean here's the CSS
for component which uses a hypothetical
container query syntax you start by
applying base styles to an element and
if these Styles apply they're defined
just on the element so they apply in all
situations then you add additional
styles for when the container is 36 or
why
and you add even more styles for when
the container is 48 m/s or wider this is
really similar to how we do mobile first
design today now imagine you replace
those hypothetical pseudo-class
functions with actual classes so of
course this isn't magic it only works if
those classes are in the Dom that's the
only way they'll apply and then they
have to be automatically added and
removed if the container changes size it
would have to work a little bit like
this in this example notice how the
classes are added and removed from the
container as the Box gets bigger and
then smaller
so the question is can we make this work
and if so how so this is exactly where
resize observer comes into play and why
it's so great so here's some code that
uses recycled server that implements the
exact logic that I showed you in the
previous slide and it's actually not
that much code so let's step through it
so the first thing you do is create a
resize observer instance and then you
pass it a callback function now this
callback function is invoked anytime the
elements at your observing change their
size you get passed a list of elements
because sometimes more than one element
can change at the same time and then
you're given kind of more details in
those so in the next function we just
saw we define a set of break point names
and their respective minimum lists this
is just kind of our mapping between the
break point names we're going to use and
the the width that we decide then we
loop through our list of break points
for each changed element and then if the
elements width is larger than the
minimum width for that break point we
add the break point class the element
and if it's smaller than that with we
remove the class next we set a data
attribute on the element indicating that
the resize observer is now active it's
now monitoring this element and this
step is technically optional but it's
actually really useful for styling the
element in CSS if you want to because
it's often the case that you don't want
to show an element until its initial
breakpoint is set
finally we query for all container
elements in the DOM and we start
observing them so I should point out
that the callback only gets invoked for
changes to observe elements so you have
to explicitly observe them it doesn't
just by default observe all elements
that would be too inefficient so some of
you might share the opinion expressed in
this tweet by Zack Leatherman and while
I understand the send sentiment and I do
think a pure CSS solution and ultimately
be best I want to point out that even
though this technique uses JavaScript it
doesn't depend on it it doesn't break
without it or if any there's any errors
with the JavaScript so if you look at
the CSS again you'll notice that I
define the initial set of base styles
that don't have any breakpoint classes
attached so if the user has javascript
disabled or for whatever reason there's
an error when trying to run it these
base styles
still apply it's just like if you load a
mobile website on your desktop browser
it might look a little bit weird but
it's still completely usable so this is
actually a textbook example of
progressive enhancement so I don't see
any issues with the fact that this
strategy uses JavaScript and even in
cases where javascript is disabled or if
there's an error running it we can use
CSS to guarantee that our components
will always be displayed because errors
of JavaScript are not going to affect
the CSS this is actually a great kind of
use case for CSS so we define an
animation with a two second initial
delay that fades in for each container
element I think if the JavaScript fails
for some reason the container element
the container element will still become
visible at most two seconds after the
CSS is loaded and when our resize
observer code runs and usually it will
run sooner than that we just remove the
animation and so everything works as
normal lastly we add a no script tag so
if javascript is turned off entirely we
show the elevant no matter what we don't
have that that delay so if you're
building a complex web application that
requires container queries there's a
good chance your application is already
using a component architecture whether
that's something like react or native
web components you can easily handle
dynamic Dom by hooking into into your
components lifecycle methods for example
with custom elements you can hook into
the connected callback which gets
invoked when the element is added to the
DOM and then you can automatically
observe new container elements as
they're created at some point you don't
have to worry about on observing removed
elements because that automatically gets
handled by garbage collection the other
really nice thing about using custom
elements is then you can give them more
meaningful names like this you can also
really easily define base container
class that all other responsive
components can extend or behaviors that
they can mix in so I know it's not cool
to show a slide with minified code at a
conference but the point that I'm hoping
to make here is that even though this is
a JavaScript based solution it's not
like you're downloading all of NPM to
make it
100% of the code to make this work both
the CSS and the JavaScript is on this
slide right here and this is actually
hand transpile at the es5 so it will
work in I 11 as well and also note
assume this assumes that the browser
supports resize observer so if you want
to use this code on a browser that
doesn't support resize observer you can
load a polyfill but remember you don't
actually have to load the polyfill
because if the polyfill if the browser
doesn't support resize observer or if
there's an error you just get the base
tiles so to prove that this technique
works
I built a demo site a few months ago
that showcases tons of responsive
components and you can resize them in a
variety of different ways and the UI is
supposed to kind of mimic common
patterns that I see in the wild so in
this case you know the sidebars are
expandable and collapsible and this pain
is resizable by the user and so there's
no way to handle situations like this
with media queries because you have no
idea whether users preference will be
and what size they'll make these content
areas so the demo is built with regular
Dom as well as custom elements so you
can see examples of both and all the
source code is clearly linked from the
site so you can dive in and see how it's
implemented and lastly I want to
emphasize that the site works cross
browser it's not like a chrome only
thing it even works in IE and it even
works when javascript is turned off so
even though resize observers chrome only
this demo shows that it's that it's not
a good enough reason not to use the
technique it kind of it could definitely
work everywhere it's progressive
enhancement like I said before so to
come summarize the current state of
affairs
well CSS container queries don't exist
in the form developers have been asking
for there's lots of ways to mimic this
behavior with current web technologies
the strategy I've outlined here is what
I consider to be the best way to build
responsive components today it's
performant it's easy to implement it
doesn't require any specific JavaScript
framework or bits build tool and it even
works without JavaScript entirely so now
that we've discussed the past and the
present let's take a quick look at the
future to see what that might bring so
the good news is that the w3c through
the web in commuter community
has actually restarted the container
query efforts and this is being led by
contact from Mozilla and the new spec is
being edited by Tommy Hodgins who's the
creator of the EQ CSS polyfill so while
it's impossible to say for sure what the
future will bring
let me leave you with a couple of my
predictions first browsers are
definitely not gonna be making the web
slower this means that any future
container query solution will likely be
built on top of existing optimizations
like CSS containment and resize observer
second I think web components and things
like layered API s will be a big part of
this future I can imagine we ship
something like a declarative resize
observer element or component that
requires you know strict CSS containment
that way browsers can really easily
optimize for it as a side note if you're
not familiar with layered web api's talk
to me about this afterwards it's a
really exciting new idea finally I think
that some of the experimentation
browsers are doing currently with
parallel rendering and async layout
might lead to breakthroughs in the
efficiency we can do layout but even if
that happens I still don't think
container queries will be implemented if
they require a multi pass rendering I
mean you can imagine if layout suddenly
becomes ten times faster in some browser
I don't think that browser is then gonna
lose that entire speed gain to implement
a slow peach slow feature most likely
they would be just shouting from the
rooftops about how much faster their
browser is in the competition so for
some final thoughts
first of all resize observer finally
gives us the ability to build ultra
performant truly responsive components
so please try out the API and if you
build anything cool definitely share it
a second CSS containment is an amazing
advancement in layout performance and
will likely shape the future of
container queries if you haven't used it
you should try that out as well it can
make your site feel much much faster
third browser makers and web developers
definitely shouldn't feel like they're
at war with each other they should be
working together but don't forget that
while browser makers want to please web
developers their ultimate responsibility
is to their users
and that's who we as web developers
should care most about as well so let's
make the web faster for everybody thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]